with all the information that I have we
would not have
started the reason is that there was so
well-funded players uh in the industry
at that point of time that thinking that
we able to beat them just because our
value propostion is different seems
crazy and hence I often believe that to
start something of your own you need to
have this irrational sense of
optimism because if you logically
discuss too much then of course you'll
find 100 reason why it can't be done and
why it has not been done till now
because as a startup you are doing
something which is unique so if I go
back I think I will not have the courage
to start I'll will be too scared of the
other players having so much of funding
but we were in our own Zone we thought
just okay we can do our own
thing welcome to 20-minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of makea wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
ctec Amit Kar welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you I'm good thank you for
having me thank you for joining me I'll
be from Bangalore I me you're working on
some really really really cool things
with nobroker.com a proptech
unicorn the journey besides that s it's
fascinating and I'm excited to
unfold what happened there with your own
joury getting into proptech house
hunting no broker and and building it up
as an entrepreneur so I maybe before
even we get started started into
proptech and this whole world take me
back to your own self your own
upbringing what sort of connect the dots
for me if you well looking back sure so
I am an engineer from I kpur and MBA
from
imhad both of these colleges are number
one engineering and number one MV
College in India uh so from education
perspective I
was I was pretty decent and then I
joined Consulting um and I consulted
Banks and financial services for almost
10 years and afterwards I was heading
strategy AZ Bank austral newand bank uh
for India U and then it felt as if the
life has become very comfortable good
salary and life is just cruising along
and I thought it's important to give it
a shock and try something uh which
basically brings me out of the comfort
zone wow and so you're you're in that
comfort zone
well you're you have a lot of different
options to go by that route was it clear
to you that entrepreneurship starting
your own company was going to be you
know the right way to get out of the
comfort zone for you uh I think this was
always in my mind that I want to start
something of my own afterz I was giving
an interview and the person who was
interviewing me he was the founder and
there was a quote which is which was
written on the back of the wall and the
quote is by Mark Zuckerberg which says
that not taking risk in life is the
biggest
risk and I think that was basically a
turning point where I felt that when I
am interviewing with this founder why
shouldn't I take risk if you don't take
a risk despite having good educational
and professional background then when
will you take the RK completely okay so
put me in that situation you're sitting
there you're figuring out okay I'm going
to take the risk I'm going to go on this
journey what is the process that you go
through to identify exactly what that
journey is going to be so the way in
which I thought was there are two ways
one way is to basically for many people
in India one way is to see what has
already been successful in say us or
China and try to emulate that the way in
which I thought was that let me just
look at what personal issues I face in
my daily life and how would I would want
to solve it and we had I had shifted to
multiple cities because of my management
consulting background and Indian Brokers
are very very different from say us
Brokers and the experience was very bad
and we thought that let's basically do
something which solves our
problem so let's let's expand on that
you're the problem of of house hunting
and Brokers paint me the landscape here
sure so uh so for your audience in
perhaps in countries like us and China
and other developed countries also the a
broker is registered he has some
accountability right India there is no
registered entity called broker or agent
and the owner gives his house for
renting and for selling to multiple
brokers in parallel uh with no
affiliation with no commitment either
side so what happens is that broker in
India has become an entity which is just
sharing the phone number no regist no
accountability and everything is
collected in cash so no income tax on
that which basically means a grocery
shop shop guy also becomes a part-time
broker which means their objective is
just to close a deal and extremely poor
customer service and no help in terms of
property management or Packers movers
nothing so I will just match two people
and I'll take the money and I'll run
away and the money is one of the highest
in the world so for a 11mon rental
contract a broker in India takes one
month from of rent from owner and one
month of rent as brokerage from tenant
Wow rent for 11 Monon rental contract
it's mindblowing unbelievable
unbelievable why why did it take so long
or it still is I mean why is it the way
this Market evolved unlike in the United
States for example where it's a
registered entity what happened here
that this that this sort of fell through
the cracks I think what has happened is
the country has 10 other things to focus
on be INF which the country is doing now
very well there so many things are there
and Brokers have become a very powerful
Lobby over years and you would not
believe that there is a 19 billion
dollar worth of brokerage which is paid
by Common Man in India every year
imagine this a big amount of
inefficiency and Brokers have made a
tested cartle so in India there is
unlike us or China there is no branded
broker chain there are zero so every guy
is's a individual broker and then
another broker which basically means an
and a and a asset cartle that nobody can
charge less everybody will charge equal
and which which is
high so if I'm a broker in India up
until
now how would I go about even finding
you know how how would I go about you
know identifying the opportunities to
become this middleman who takes the
crazy cut from both sides what what
would I do sure so Michael you can come
to India
tomorrow uh despite not being an Indian
citizen you just need couple of phone
numbers of owners and whose property is
vacant for tency or for buy and sell and
you can have a small shop there or you
can have existing shop and you can just
put a board and any tenant in that
vicinity will walk in and you will say
okay I'll show you this house you will
you'll take him to that house and if he
likes that house you take the money you
take the money in cash and then you can
fly back there's no problem so that is
how uh low an entry barrier is and that
is how low the accountability is so all
sort of spurious uh people have come
into the business there of course good
brok but they are very few a large
amount of have come for very for quick
money wow that's a okay it sounds like a
quite a battle that you entered into I
can definitely see the opportunity I can
see the challenges let's talk about them
so is you're going into building no
broker what are you facing really
besides the fake be besides you know
the fact that technologically you have
to build it the product has to be good
okay we'll talk about that in a second
but it sounds like there's some consumer
Behavior there's some economics here
that you're that you're breaking and
that you're disrupting which probably
has some unintended consequences that
you have to deal with how how
complicated is it so what basically
happened was that we uh uh when we
started we said that we will solve it
with the help of technology which
basically okay makes sense and then what
started happening was that once we built
the platform once we started connecting
the owners and tenants directly with
each other without any broker so we used
the elgo through which we we banned the
Brokers on the platform and one fine day
when we very small we saw a group of 60
70 Brokers outside our office now we
thought that they were some some
political procession but they were
Brokers and they came to break computer
beat our employes
and you wouldn't believe Bangalore is
such an advanced City with is a capital
and they slapped our employees we called
police thankfully Grill door that we
held on to else it would have been a
mayham so our office was attacked by a
group of 60 70
Brokers wow okay you're the CEO how do
you go from there what do you do what
happens the next day so it's extremely
difficult because the moment it happened
many of the female employees started
crying and uh and we called police but
basically Brokers then just went away
and the next day they again started
coming so what they started doing was
they started chasing the female
employees from the office towards their
home the damage the motorbikes which
people had parked so it was
horrible and because because many of the
spurious elements have entered into this
business so they in their mind they
thought they don't have a concept of
cloud so they thought that if they
destroy the office the company is
destroyed uh but you just take the
laptop and move somewhere else so then
we basically uh changed the office
almost overnight we did not have any
office and we shifted to two temporary
offices and of course the customer helpl
line phone line had to be disconnected
and the Brokers chased us in the night
when we were taking the computers in the
vehicle away from the office to know
about a new address that was the
situation then we hid our uh office
address from Google uh for next 5 years
because we did not even today if you
come to no broker office there is no
facade outside the building we don't say
no
broker that's
crazy this is
unbelievable yeah and this does not
happen often in India I would say this
is a rare event uh but this also
basically shows that
so our investors told us that perhaps
you are doing something disruptive which
is why the us while players are
basically upset so this is a good sign
as for them I said this might be a good
sign but this is hugely inconvenient and
hugely problematic for us uh and the but
the team became very stronger Michael
this is surprising that after a external
event like this as a team disintegrating
team became very strong because it felt
that we are not just doing a job we are
fighting for a cause certainly it
basically trans formed into that it
really trans it sounds like it
transformed into a mission you got to
witness what that mission is all about
firsthand it's so I can only imagine
what this may do to to the employees
there which is qu quite incredible tell
me a little bit about no broker and how
you've built it so connecting with with
the new time the owners taking out the
Brokers you know and cutting the
middlemen and providing a a a more valid
them in the more I guess um intimate and
real way for for this whole transaction
to happen What were what was the Fe
that's going into no broker platform and
what how does it look like so what
happens is that now if you come on no
grer platform as a owner you can poster
property for free as a tenant as a buyer
you can come on no grou platform and you
can contact a owner or seller
directly without any middlen in between
we have we offer a Premium plan so so
you can do it directly free of cost and
we have some value added plans in which
we highlight your property and we give
you more contacts and so on uh through
which we make money uh but broadly what
happens is that whatever if you are
paying a broker at $300 of rental
brokerage now you end up paying $50 so
we basically crashed the intermediation
fees
to6 uh and uh buyers and tenants
initially were very surprised that
really will I really be able to contact
the property owner isn't there hidden
fees and we said no because we don't
have any physical people on the field we
have zero people to click photos we
because owners only send us the photos
and we have only one office uh we don't
need to have physical presence
everywhere everything is Technology
based so the way in which Facebook
connects content creators and content
consumers same way we basically create
owners and Seekers uh together we don't
have the we don't create the content we
we just enable to post it but through
this way we have been able to disrupt
the industry uh today after 8 years we
have cumulative uh 20 million customers
on the
platform um and now the pace of growth
is so massive that we are adding 7.5
million new customers per year uh and uh
we have raised funding from all top
investors tiger Global from US general
Atlantic from us so we have raised
around 350 million doar till now and we
are the first proptech unicorn in the
country I'm not the believable if you're
looking at it from me first of all
congratulations on on the whole journey
on the personal side on the
entrepreneurial side it's
inspiring were were there some
unintended consequences to cutting out
the Brokers from this chain if you're
looking at the disruption besides the
the impact that's caused on your
yourself and your employees were there
some unintended consequences or some
interesting you know circumstances that
evolved as a result of changing and
disrupting this these economics I think
two things one from the customer side
one from our realization side from
customer side I think we have been very
blessed to get huge amount of Praise
from customers because they as an Indian
they always wanted to basically avoid a
broker and deal with each other directly
but there was no way in earlier so and I
think the The Testament is basically the
customers who are coming no matter how
much funding you raise you can never get
7.5 million new customer per year unless
you are doing something which is helping
the customers second thing is a
realization which is a positive
unintended consequence we realize that
many of the other Industries are also
broken for example in India the Packers
and movers is a very broken industry
with very few branded players so we
started Packers and movers not the truck
ourselves but trucks basically with the
with those contractors but we take money
on the platform and then we connect with
the contractor uh who will do the labor
work today we are also India's largest
Packer and mover
agregator wow and then we also realize
that as far as painting is concerned
cleaning is concerned home interior is
concerned home loan intermediation is
concerned P for them also India is a
very broken Market with fragmented
players and poor customer NBS so that
also we entered and so from Real Estate
we basically then Diversified into the
entire real estate Journey chain uh and
we became number one in couple of them
that's incredible so if you had to
estimate how many how many people in
India had the benefit of using no broker
to to get something done to accomplish
some partnership or some transaction
without the hassle and the extra costs
of a middleman do you have a a number
like that in in might so till now 20
million people have registered on no and
our estimate wow our estimate so all of
them have either posted a property or
have spoken to a owner and tenant so all
of these 20 million people have
benefited in some way or another many of
them their services multiple times over
the past 8 years uh and now they keep on
using us for painting for cleaning for
home loan and so on so
forth do you have a mechanism for
closing the feedback loop so that things
can become more personal and more
curated or you can learn about consumer
Behavior what works and what doesn't
work yeah this is a this a very good
question Michael so for example in us I
think the data is extremely updated so
what I'm told is that in us if a deal
happens on on a particular Street within
California in this city this data is
available but in India it is not
available so in India this data is is
opaque and the government doesn't
publish this data so we are the only
platform in the country because we don't
take the transaction away the broker T
the transaction away so we are the only
play is this data so now we publish this
data we publish the price trends uh so I
think this was something which was not
available before but because we are
doing the transaction because we are
only so today we are not the largest
real estate platform in the country but
we are the largest customer to customer
platform in the world so there's no
other platform in the world there are
for example Zillow and Trulia they are B
Toc broker to customer but we are the
only and similarly right move in prime
location say in UK but we are the only
customer to customer platform in the
entire world who is so
large correct that's um that's pretty
great wel me back to now you know we
started the show or this episode with uh
you talking about you know what um you
know the why you entered this journey
and why you you know why this whole
thing started looking back
was that the right move for
you yes it was but if I look back with
all the information that I have we would
not have
started the reason is that there was so
well-funded players uh in the industry
at that point of time that thinking that
we able to beat them just because our
value proportion is different seems
crazy and hence I often believe that to
start something of your own you need to
have have this irrational sense of
optimism because if you logically
discuss too much then of course you'll
find 100 reason why it can't be done and
why it has not been done till now
because as a startup you are doing
something which is unique so if I go
back I think I will not have the courage
to start I'll be too scared of the other
players having so much of funding but we
were in our own Zone we thought just
okay we can do our own
thing I love that I really really love
that what what did you enjoy most about
this journe so far
I think two things one is the growth
because growth pumps you it gives you
more confidence and uh validates your
effort and second thing is working with
the team so I think every day when I
come to office I'm very blessed to have
an amazing team we have now close to
4,000 people on the uh on the bay roll
and out of which the top 100 people who
run this company uh they are extremely
talented best pedigree very passionate
and having like 100 co-founders so
coming to office daily talking to them
now it's a reverse motivation it's them
who basically inspire me so that is the
most interesting
part I love that am me thank you so much
for coming here and for sharing with me
this journey this is such an enjoyable
and inspiring
episode I I just love the stories I love
the motivation and the journey itself
was amazing so thank you very very much
for being here and best of luck with uh
the remaining journey of no broker
thanks a lot Mike
oh